for now the saudi-led military coalition
continues its assault from the air
carrying out strikes on 100 locations in
Yemen in the last 24 hours but there
could soon be a let up in the fighting
Houthi rebels have agreed to a five-day
ceasefire due to begin on Tuesday night
it is our hope and our desire that the
hoses will come to their senses and
realize that the interests of Yemen and
the Yemeni people are should be the top
priority for everyone the conflict has
wreaked havoc in Yemen these images are
from the port city of Aden it's scene
intense fighting between Houthi rebels
and forces loyal to yemen's exiled
president ah Bravo Mansour Hadi hundreds
of civilians have been killed many in
saudi air strikes
the conflict in Yemen has increased
regional tensions sunni-ruled Saudi
Arabia accuses Sheehan let Iran of
providing the Houthi rebels with
financial and military backing iran
denies this Tuesday's ceasefire will
allow much-needed deliveries of haydn to
Yemen it's also fueled hopes that a
diplomatic solution may still be
possible